♪ (intro music) ♪
Being able to arbitrarily combine
and overlay widgets atop one another,
it's simple in Flutter
using the Stack widget.
But how do you position
those widgets in a Stack?
There is a couple of ways you can do this.
And one of them is
to use a Positioned widget.
You know, for positioning things.
Which is kind of self-explanatory
when you think about it.
So how does Positioned work?
First, let's wrap a widget in a Stack
with a Positioned widget.
Then, use a combination of the parameters
top, bottom, left, right,
height, and width
to position the widget within the Stack.
Here, we see a widget placed 25 down
from the top, and 50 in from the left.
And here, we have the widget
placed at 25 from the right,
and 50 up from the bottom.
You can use height and width to control
the size of the Positioned widget.
And one last tip.
You can use Positioned.fill
to make the widget fill the Stack's space.
For more info on Positioned
and Stack layout,
head on over to flutter.io.
♪ (music) ♪